you have a new movie that's what it now
let's talk about covid
and the new movie because now it's a
different way of selling a movie in
other words
yes i would imagine you guys had in your
mind this was going to be a theatrical
release
correct yes we did yes yes we were
hoping for that
and now in our new universe we don't
even know what a movie theater looks
like where do you see it
yeah well it's it's going to be on pvod
and then any you can
wherever if you run
premium video on demand
you can google people but i don't know
what's going on
and i couldn't find it you found some
other things
the movie is called star go to vista del
mar
uh your leading man is this character
from fifty shades of grey good looking
guy
and you do have love scenes with him was
there an onset romance as many have
predicted
the
you chose him personally did you
audition other people how did this come
about
well he was sort of like the the
prototype when we were writing it
and um you know we wanted this sort of
like
uh james bondi uh
someone who is known for more serious
acting and maybe doesn't have a comedic
background and
it was like well yeah i mean jamie
dornan you know when you're picking
jimmy if you would ever like well he'll
never do it
but like like a jamie dornan and then we
sent him the script and then it's like
he's reading it and we're like oh my god
he's reading it and then we were like oh
my god we're like embarrassed like oh my
god he's reading it
and then it's like oh he wants to get on
the phone with josh and then he talked
to the director and then
when we found out he was doing it it was
like
uh what well we have a new kristen wiig
movie
it is barb and star go to vista del mar
and
you couldn't have a better location for
a movie vista del mar what a beautiful
what a beautiful flat beautiful place
that's right